so this is a classic example
in uh uh graphical models probabilistic
models um
so if you what are those um okay
um i think it's useful to mention
because we'll talk about them more
yeah yeah so neural networks are one
class
of machine learning models um you know
you have
distributed set of uh nodes which are
called the neurons
you know each one is doing a dot product
and you can you can approximate any
function using this a multi-level
network of neurons so that's
a class of models which are used for
useful for function approximation
there is another class of models in
machine learning uh called probabilistic
graphical models
and you can think of them as each node
in that
model is variable which is which is
talking about something you know
it can be a variable representing is is
an edge
present in the input or not uh and at
the
top of the uh network a
node can be uh representing is there an
object present in the world or not and
and
then so it can it is it is another way
of encoding knowledge
and uh um and then you
once you encode the knowledge you can
uh do inference in the right way you
know how what is the best way to
you know explain some set of evidence
using this model that you encoded you
know so when you encode the model
you are encoding the relationship
between these different variables how is
the edge
connected to my uh the model of the
object how is the surface connected to
the model of the object
um and then um of course this is a very
distributed complicated model
and inference is how do you
explain a piece of evidence when a set
of stimulus comes in if somebody tells
me
there is a 50 probability that there is
an edge here in this part of the model
how does that affect my belief on
whether
i should think that there should be is
the square percent in the image
so so this is the process of inference
so
one example of inference is having this
experience of effect between
multiple causes so uh graphical models
can be
used to represent causality in the world
um
so let's say um you know uh your
uh alarm uh at home
can be uh triggered by a
a burglar getting into your house or it
can be triggered by
an earthquake both both can be causes of
the alarm going off
so now you you're right you know you're
in your office you heard
burglar alarm going off you are heading
uh home
thinking that there's a burglar but
while driving home
if you hear on the radio that there was
an earthquake in the vicinity
now your hype you know uh strength of
evidence for
a burglar getting into their house is
diminished
because now that that piece of evidence
is explained by
the earthquake being present so if you
if you think about these two causes
explaining a lower level uh variable
which is alarm
now what we're seeing is that increasing
the evidence for some cause
ex you know there is evidence coming in
from below for alarm being present
and initially it was flowing to a
burglar
being present but now since somebody
some this
there is side evidence for this other
cause it explains away this evidence and
it evidence will now flow to the other
course
this is you know two competing causal uh
things trying to explain the same
evidence
you